vamos a practicar cómo calcular rangos
inter cuartil es aquí he copiado algunos
ejercicios del portal de khan academy
para resolverlos en el pizarrón
electrónico los siguientes datos
representan el número de galletas de
animalitos en el almuerzo de cada niño
ordena los datos de menor a mayor
encuentran el rango inter cuartil del
conjunto de datos y te invito a que
tratas de resolver esto por tu cuenta
antes de que veamos la solución ok vamos
a resolverlo juntos si hiciéramos esto
en la sección de ejercicios de khan
academy podríamos tomar estos datos y
cambiarlos de lugar para ordenar los de
mayor a menor
pero aquí esta vez lo haremos a mano
primero busquemos el dato más pequeño
que parece ser el 4 así que lo voy a
anotar por aquí luego tengo este otro 4
también lo voy a anotar acá abajo
y veamos hay algún 5 no pero hay un 6
así que también lo notaré acá abajo
después tengo un 7
veamos tengo 18 nov 9 tampoco pero tengo
un 10 entonces lo pondré aquí
también tengo un 11 también lo notaré
por acá
tengo 112 de lujo
tengo también un 14 y ya casi acabamos
me falta solamente el 15
muy bien ahora lo primero que
necesitamos hacer es encontrar la
mediana la mediana es el dato que está
en medio así que aquí tengo 123456789
datos por lo que tendremos sólo un dato
en el médium tenemos una cantidad impar
de datos así que será el número que
tenga cuatro datos a la derecha y cuatro
datos a la izquierda y ese número en
medium nuestra mediana serán este 10
observa tengo cuatro datos a la
izquierda y cuatro datos a la derecha de
este 10 ahora bien para encontrar el
rango inter cuartil lo que haremos es
encontrar la diferencia entre la mediana
de la primera mitad y la mediana de la
segunda mitad es una medida de
dispersión una forma de medir qué tan
separados están estos datos
por lo tanto vamos a calcular la mediana
de la primera mitad para eso ignoremos
la mediana de todos los datos es decir
vamos a ignorar a este 10 y vamos a
enfocarnos en estos primeros 4 datos y
como tengo 4 datos es decir un número
par de datos entonces voy a calcular la
mediana promediando estos dos datos que
estén en medio el promedio de 4 y 6 va a
hacer 5
o podemos decir que cuatro más seis está
dividido entre dos es lo mismo
que 10 entre 2
lo cual es lo mismo que 5
y ahora en la segunda mitad también
vamos a calcular la mediana vamos a
hacer lo mismo tenemos cuatro números y
nos vamos a fijar en los datos que están
en medium que son el 12 y el 14 ok ahora
calculamos el promedio de 12 y 14 y este
va a ser 13
o podemos escribirlo 12-14
esto dividido entre 2 es lo mismo que 26
entre 2
qué es lo mismo que 13 también la forma
fácil de promediar estos datos es ver
cuál es el dato que está en la mitad de
12-14 que es 13 ya los tenemos aquí la
mediana de la primera mitad es 5 y la
mediana de la segunda mitad es 13 ahora
para calcular el rango inter cuartil
tenemos que calcular la diferencia entre
estas dos cantidades por lo que el rango
inter cuartil
va a ser igual a 13 menos 5 lo cual es
la mediana de la segunda mitad menos la
mediana de la primera mitad y esto es
igual a 88 galletas de animalitos bien
hagamos otro ejercicio como este son
bastante interesantes
encuentran el rango inter cuartil de los
datos en la siguiente gráfica de puntos
las canciones en cada álbum de la
colección de jane y observa tengo esta
gráfica de puntos como siempre los
invito a que traten de resolverlo aquí
tenemos los datos representados de una
manera diferente pero podemos ordenar la
información vamos a hacerlo aquí abajo
tengo un álbum con siete canciones por
lo tanto voy a poner aquí un 7
después tengo dos álbumes con nueve
canciones así que voy a escribir dos
nueves
después tengo tres álbumes con 10
canciones así que voy a escribir 3 veces
después tengo un álbum con 11 canciones
después dos álbumes con 12 canciones
y por último tengo un álbum con 14
canciones
ok todo lo que hice fue tomar esta
información y le expresé acá abajo hay
un álbum con siete canciones un álbum
con nueve canciones otro álbum con nueve
canciones otro con diez canciones
etcétera además la forma en la que
escribí los datos me ayudó a tenerlos en
orden por lo que puedo comenzar a
calcular la mediana directamente tenemos
uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete
ocho nueve diez datos es una cantidad
para por lo que para calcular la mediana
debo de fijarme en estos dos datos que
tengo a la mitad y esos datos son estos
dos dieces observa tengo cuatro datos a
la izquierda y cuatro datos a la derecha
de estos dos dieces calcular la mediana
de dos datos es encontrar el dato que
están a la mitad de ellos o de otra
manera hay que promediar estos dos datos
pero el promedio de 10 y 10 va a ser
simplemente 10 así que déjame escribirlo
10 va a ser nuestra mediana
y en un caso como éste en donde calculé
la mediana usando los datos de enmedio
puedo incluir el primer 10 el 10 de la
izquierda en la primera mitad y el
segundo 10 el de la derecha en la
segunda mitad
entonces me queda que la primera mitad
son estos 5 datos y mi segunda mitad van
a ser estos otros 5 datos y esto es
lógico porque estoy dividiendo a todo mi
conjunto
justo a la mitad 5 de un lado y 5 del
otro si tuviéramos un dato justo en el
medio como en el ejemplo anterior lo
ignore haríamos y así formaríamos
nuestra primera mitad en nuestra segunda
mitad o al menos es así como lo estamos
haciendo en estos ejemplos entonces
encontramos la mediana de la primera
mitad
si tengo 5 datos estos de aquí entonces
tenemos una cantidad impar de datos por
lo tanto vamos a tener un solo dato la
mitad y será aquel con dos datos de amd
la 2 y es justo este 9 de aquí el dato
de medium de la primera mitad es 9 la
mediana de la segunda mitad donde
tenemos 12 345 datos es este 12 de aquí
que está justo en medio con dos datos a
la derecha y dos datos a la izquierda
entonces el rango inter cuartil de todo
este conjunto va a ser la diferencia de
la mediana de la segunda mitad menos la
mediana de la primera mitad así que el
rango inter cuartil va a ser igual a
bueno tengo 12 que es la mediana de la
segunda mitad y ya esto le voy a quitar
9 que es la mediana de la primera mitad
y esto me va a dar
si resolvemos esto en el portal de
ejercicios escribiríamos un 3 justo aquí
como respuesta y hemos acabado nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo